- [Voiceover] We’re told, "the
graph of the function f of x
"is equal to x-squared."
We see it right over here in grey.
It’s shown in the grid below.
"Graph the function g of x is equal to
"x minus two-squared, minus four
"in the interactive graph."
This is from the shifting
functions exercise
on Khan Academy, and we can see
we can change the graph of g of x.
But let’s see, we want
to graph it properly,
so let’s see how they relate.
Well, let’s think about a few things.
Let’s first just make g
of x completely overlap.
Okay, there you go.
Now they're completely overlapping.
And let’s see how they’re different.
Well, g of x, if you look
at what's going on here,
instead of having an x-squared,
we have an x minus two-squared.
So, one way to think about
it is, when x is zero,
you have zero-squared is equal to zero.
But how do you get zero here?
Well, x has got to be equal to two.
Two minus two-squared is zero-squared,
if we don’t look at the
negative four just yet.
And so, we would want to shift this graph
over two to the right.
This is essentially how much
do we shift to the right.
It’s sometimes a little
bit counterintuitive
that we have a negative there,
because you might say, well, negative,
that makes me think that I
want to shift to the left.
But you have to remind yourself is like,
well okay, for the original graph,
when it was just x-squared,
to get the zero-squared, I
just have to put x equals zero.
Now to get a zero-squared,
I have to put in a two.
So this is actually shifting
the graph to the right.
And so, what do we do
with this negative four?
Well, this is a little bit more intuitive,
or at least for me when
I first learned it.
This literally will just
shift the graph down.
Whatever your value is
of x minus two-squared,
it's gonna shift it down by four.
So what we wanna do is just shift
both of these points down by four.
So this is gonna go from nine,
and this is gonna go from the
coordinate five comma nine,
to five comma, if we go
down four, five comma five.
And this is gonna go from two comma zero,
to two comma negative four.
Two comma negative four.
Did I do that right?
I think that’s right.
What, essentially, what
we have going on is,
g of x is f of x shifted two
to the right and four down.
Two to the right and four down.
And notice, if you look
at the vertex here,
we shifted two to the right and four down.
And I shifted this one also,
this one also I shifted
two to the right, and four down.
And, there you have it.
We have graphed g of x,
which is a shifted version of f of x.